[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 170 q and a
segment it is still Earth day it is
still Earth Day uh we're gonna have to
do this a little quickly today we forgot
to say that earlier but uh we're gonna
get through as many questions as we can
and not too much time without further
Ado let us start we're going to start
with I always forget to say this in the
first hour we always have a question
from the Discord server every week they
vote on what question they most want to
ask us this week and it is this
you ready
you sure
say for sure until you tell me what the
question is but uh you're sitting down
now I am okay can I do this
all right
you two have a wonderful Dynamic and
obvious love and respect for each other
which many of your listeners find
inspiring I just got engaged to a fellow
Dark Horse podcast listener a man I met
on the Dark Horse Discord
hell yeah that is awesome what is your
best advice for young married couples
well I will give you big
big questions it's a little late for my
best advice but hopefully this applies
to you and if not nah it's gonna apply
what's late why is it too late for your
best advice you'll see the advice I give
people is
um never consider a long-term
relationship especially marriage with
somebody who does not have a sense of
humor it's not funny
good one
um but
so anyway you've gotten engaged
presumably you've passed each other's
tests certainly you both laughed a lot
if you're Dark Horse listeners you're
gonna have a sense of humor about
yourself I I feel I feel that that is
likely to be uh near Universal if not
Universal amongst people who actually
put up with us so
um anyway uh mazel tov
sure
um but you know the point is the sense
of humor about yourself the fact that
you are not synonymous with your
conscious mind which means that you're
bringing a lot of stuff to a
relationship
that uh
both you and your partner are spectators
too
right so I will give I will give this
example there's lots of stuff about me
that's not great for relationship and
it's not stuff that I would defend my
when I say me I mean the conscious me
and the conscious me is not in favor of
those things either so you know the
ability to recognize that you bring
stuff to a relationship that you
wouldn't bring if you were you know
choosing all of your features a la carte
is an important
um
an important
tool in the Arsenal of navigating the
complex relationship that is marriage
but our features aren't a la carte right
we can't
uh unlike what many sort of a historical
a scientific reductionist approaches to
things today would have us believe say
ah I want a child who shall have this
characteristic and this one and this one
and this one oh and over there like this
and that's the thing I want
um we are of course the result of um
complex not just evolutionary but
especially developmental history and
um some of
hmm
I'm just going to keep talking about you
because you started but you know some of
the characteristics that you have that
do make you particularly challenging to
live with are in trade-off relationship
with some of your greatest strengths
yeah in fact I don't think either of us
knew that when we got together when we
were 20 right or when we became friends
when we were 16. right I don't think we
were thinking that way
um
but it you can't
there is no magic wand that could
disappear the frustrating things because
with it then would go the other things
in the trade-off
well there are two ways that that can
work some of the things are linked
developmentally and there's no reason
that if you got rid of the frustrating
part no after they're both already laid
down right right but the point is they
effectively have that linkage because
you can't separate your you couldn't
have gotten here without them both but
now if you could yeah and who you are
like what you know what you know
whatever some some technique to like get
rid of some of the
some of some of the things on one side
of the trade-off now that the
development process is over yep um would
be possible but you said there were two
things
um
so there's two ways the relationship can
work you can have a developmental
linkage where some defect is connected
to some strength but you could get rid
of the defect it wouldn't you know you
still develop the strength but then
there are other things and I think a lot
of my characteristics are this way it's
not even that the
the there is a relationship between the
two characteristics they're they're the
same characteristic right it's just that
in some contexts they're good and in
some contexts they're lousy and you know
those things aren't separable even uh in
even in principle
to the um
question of sort of you know advice to
Young to young couples one of the things
that we did a lot in the first 10 years
of our relationship and to some degree
in the second 10 years as well
um but especially in our 20s was we
spent a lot of time apart and this is
before cell phones and by a part I mean
like I want to live on an island off the
coast of Madagascar for five months for
instance and you went to Panama and
um
and I joined you in Panama for some of
your long time there and you came to
Madagascar with me for one of my longer
field Seasons there
um but uh
my longest field season in Madagascar
you weren't there and most of the time
that you were in Panama I wasn't there
and uh and there were also shorter they
were shorter field Seasons as well like
your very first field work experience
with Bob Travers in Jamaica was we were
still in college and you went for a
quarter or seven weeks or so of a fall
quarter and I was back at Santa Cruz in
school and you know had our apartment
and our cats and everything and
um
it's super useful it's incredibly useful
it's not you know if you're newly deeply
in love it's not what you think you want
it's not what you choose it's not like
I'm looking for an opportunity to spend
time away from you if that's where you
are yeah there's a problem right
um but if you're driven to do things
um that uh that have you apart and
that's a
an unfortunate reality of it
it's remarkable what can be learned from
the time apart and I think if it was
always just one person who was going and
one person who was always attending the
Home Fires it would create a dynamic
that might be hard to
um hard to recover from fully but if
each of you occasionally
um go and you know in our case it was
months at a time but I think even a week
you know even a few days honestly even a
few days it's you know you learn
something different in months that you
do in a week or a few days I think but
um
you you learn things about uh who you
are in combination and
um and you know specifically I don't
think this is the biggest thing but the
thing that you have returned to often
that I said to you at one point after
you came back I think from Jamaica was
um and that was the first time I think
that one of us had gone yeah for any any
length of time and we had by then you
know we had spent a whole summer
traveling together in Central America
like we had done a lot of intense stuff
together
um
but I had begun already to grow
frustrated with some of um those those
things in the trade-off relationship
yeah
um the sort of the executive function
and not completing tasks exactly
precisely yes
and the sort of
chaos everywhere
um and so it was something a relief at
first like oh okay I can just like get
things clean and neat and like not have
to maintain them because they just
maintain themselves with a little bit of
input every day and that was something
of relief but I realized that
um
I had then started just putting a whole
lot of things onto your account that
didn't belong there a certain a lot of
things did but you know the fact that
you did in fact inadvertently grow
mushrooms in the carpet by your side of
the bed stands as one of the best
examples now you you are forcing me to
have to defend myself first of all use
the term clean which is not really what
you mean you were you were never it's
never great it's never enough
I did grow on my side of the bed what
happened was not on the bed on the
carpet on the carpet I left some
clothing some laundry on the floor there
were strata there was paperwork
people who are now suffering from uh
misinformation that you are inculcate no
wait a second I'm acknowledging the
mushrooms but the point is strata
can I get to why the mushrooms grew so
that they are not possessed of some
sense that I have a hygiene issue it's
not hygiene it's it's 100 not ideal it's
a neatness issue and so hold on
the laundry which should not have
remained on the floor for months or the
papers
can I finish okay
um the laundry was by the window we were
living in Santa Cruz and some rain came
in through the window and the laundry
trapped the moisture which did then
allow mushrooms to grow there but the
mushrooms were not it was a neatness
issue which is to say laundry relatively
clean laundry sitting where it shouldn't
is a neatness issue not a hygiene
mm-hmm
I think it's important but it wasn't
just laundry and it wasn't like a couple
of weeks
it was laundry and papers I'm not
however there were because it had become
frustrating to deal with a number of
these things I st I in living with you
began to assume that every frustration
that I had in the apartment that we
should in a small apartment that we
shared was clearly attributable to you
and I didn't know that I was doing this
but I I think I clearly did and I don't
remember actually something about like
the toothpaste or something like there
there were there were a number of things
that once you were gone
still continued to happen like we're
still you know vaguely irritating to me
I was like well
it's clearly not Brad He's not doing
this from Jamaica
so uh I need to be more generous and um
and careful about not uh attributing all
of the frustrations that I'm having
domestically in this space uh to him and
his presence because if they continue to
happen when he's not here clearly it's
not him all right so so the absence can
be very useful in terms of calibration
among other things yep I would say a
couple things about it though it's a
diminishing returns problem right a few
days super useful a few weeks useful at
some point in months yeah it's just it's
just not fun it's not so you know I
wouldn't say the more the better I would
just say that there's something useful
in the calibration but I wanna they're
um
your acknowledgment upon my returning
that you had discovered that some of the
stuff you were frustrated with me about
wasn't me
ant a lot to me enough that decades
later it's still a fact in the
development of our relationship that you
and I both remember right it was very
straightforward of you
to own up to it right away right that
was you know a sign of depth of
character
um and so you know I was convinced of
the depth of your character from the
beginning but nonetheless it uh it
proved out right
I wanna
tell a reverse story okay uh in which I
think uh I impressed you in this regard
you and I had a
I have no idea you may have forgotten
the story though you are about to
remember it uh uh
very clearly I think
very early in our relationship we had a
uh it wasn't an argument but a
disagreement you'd said something about
like please put the lid of the toilet
down when you're done right and I said
something like I don't get it why
doesn't every person just adjust the lid
for whatever they're about to do right
and you said well look it's very simple
right there are four scenarios you know
woman pees woman poops man pees man
poops right the only one of these for
which the lid goes up is man peas
therefore I as a woman wouldn't have to
touch that damn thing if it weren't for
your presence of the bathroom and I said
oh
now that you put it that way that's a
slam dunk that's an excellent argument
and that's you know I'm sure
occasionally I have left the seat up but
you know it's probably the only once did
I almost fall into the toilet nights all
right but but you will you will grant me
that from the moment of that argument it
has been a very rare occurrence that
I've left the seat up right so anyway I
think you know the idea that actually
there was a confusion I knew it was my
confusion as soon as you made that
argument because it was a slam dunk and
the point is how it actually Alters
Behavior because it's a good argument
why shouldn't it right yeah so those two
things I think uh give you a hint about
how to navigate these things did they
say how young they are uh I don't think
so
nope
although I do hear
from uh the lovely woman who sends me
the questions uh that this does not help
explain it but that they got engaged on
a glacier in Alaska
um yeah
all right well that's cool that's cool
that doesn't have that really gives us
no information about how old you are I
mean yeah yeah and I would also I would
also just add one more caveat before
um
uh before we let this question go which
is I don't think you're living in a
normal era and I think the importance of
uh your pair bond is
even greater than normal by
some substantial Factor
and so what I would say is
if you're right for each other
just look past all the stuff that might
ordinarily trouble you and realize that
including the mushrooms in the carpet
especially the mushrooms in the carpet
should that happen to you but look also
don't let your laundry accumulate under
a window where
rain gets in close the window
for example
they were not psychedelic mushrooms and
yes we checked yes and we would know
um but anyway uh you know if you've got
the right person
no mouse matters just
uh do what is necessary to make it work
and uh
at the extent that things are rough
um figure out how to fix it because this
is not an era in which you want
something trivial to break you up yeah
and congratulations Mazel Tov mazel tov
okay another wedding question marriage
question uh from this is now from Dark
Horse submissions and we've already
spent like 15 minutes so we're gonna
just try to get through a few of these
um how did you get married did you tweak
a classic marriage tradition as you have
with your Hanukkah tradition indeed
yeah we and I think
I think we would have been
more intentional about it
um now uh we didn't get married like
we'd been together already for gosh
eight or nine years before we got
married yep um it's actually it's gonna
be 25 years this year
uh
so
yeah we got married
outside in the Sierras in the Sierra
Nevada near Mammoth Lakes where Brett
spent a lot of time as a kid and I spent
a little bit of time as a kid
and um
and
God entered the scene just as we were
saying our vows suddenly there was an
electrical storm there was a Thunderclap
which is pretty awesome it was pretty
awesome
um we as I remember it we we borrowed a
few elements but we didn't do so from
other Traditions but we didn't do so
with a ton of uh explicit care so we did
so um I think we did the stepping on the
glass from the Jewish tradition we
didn't have a hopa or anything
um Bob trivers um perhaps the world's
greatest living evolutionary biologist
who was our undergraduate advisor was
our officiant that was fantastic he's
he's a he's a amazing man and he was our
friend it's our friend and uh and so we
got this uh sort of darwinian wedding
ceremony but he insisted on sitting down
with us beforehand a day or two
beforehand so we also we did a
backpacking trip with some of our
friends uh for the four days before we
got married so that we didn't have to be
in the thick of all of the planning
right before and so we came back like 24
hours before or something
and um
from Yosemite to Mammoth we went over
what pass to Tioga no no
[Music]
no I think it's
it's Stevenson no that's watching it
it's like it's like Davidson I can't
remember the name of the path I it will
occur to me in an hour but
um there's a frog pond up there yeah
yeah and I have a cool panoramic picture
of uh of several of us walking at the
very top above tree line um yeah anyway
um so we did that and then Uncle Bob as
as Trevor's liked us to call him
um how to sit down with him as if he had
been clergy
um to talk with us about our intentions
and specifically wanted to know if we
attended to have children
and while we had no immediate plans we
both said yeah you know ultimately yes
and um as I remember it you tell me if
uh if you remember something different
uh he said okay good then you know this
is easy you know because I you know I
know what to do if you told me that you
didn't intend to have children I don't
know exactly you know how to do
yeah he had never been an efficient
before as far as I know like we you know
you know we asked him to and he said yes
and
um but it made sense for him to honor
us coming together and and formally
bringing our lives together
um if we were ultimately going to be
bringing more lives into into the world
but he wouldn't have had as much of a
sense of what to do if we had said no
yeah in fact I mean if you think about
it from an evolutionary biologist's
perspective the idea of a marriage that
isn't about producing children in some
sense uh is some novel
Oddity yeah and you wouldn't have
necessarily known but anyway yeah
um
yeah and we had I guess two um
my oldest dearest friend and um your
maybe yours also your your best friend
from high school we had them
um Diane and John read
um did a little bit from uh rosencrans
and gildenstern are dead they did the
coin flip from from the beginning which
just baffled most the people in the
audience but we thought it was fantastic
and uh both of them I don't remember who
played rosencrantzen who played
Guildenstern but it was it was terrific
not Diane or John no thankfully yes but
Rosencrantz and also yes
um so yeah we brought a little uh
absurdist theater in the form of Tom
stopper then we it was all very
darwinian there was the Thunderclap and
the like lightning in the distance just
as we were saying about
um
yeah it was outside
and it was good yeah it was great yeah
okay
please consider a new
please consider a new anatomically
informative armadillo themed wall
hanging for future set decoration for
science or an oil painting of armadillo
and Slumber this in service of the
non-rem erections that armadillos get I
believe wondering what has come over
this person ah yes
well yes we had the armadillo up and we
the armadillo may come back up yeah this
is this is this is temporary but um
clearly this person was uh tickled
perhaps by our discussion of big harry
armadillos in their
big
hurry
I'm gonna assume that this is actually
somehow a consequence of the AGI causing
people to be bewildered and bewildering
dude we talked about those we sure did
it was I thought it was interesting
you're acting like you're embarrassed
but I don't think you actually are
um
have you not watched the movie Blackfish
it is a must-see but terribly said I
don't we haven't actually I haven't seen
a fish yeah
um it's about orcas I think it's about
orcas and I I think it is a bad work is
that we're sourced right here
oh these are the orcas that were pulled
from Salish sea and moved to Sea World
is that right that begins to start the
collapse of some of the Orca populations
up here
yeah
yes that's right
um
oh this uh this is something that came
up a few weeks ago did so this person
asked a question in the Q a of 138
um
live stream q a 138 and they ask now did
you watch your answer to my AGI question
in Q a 138 if no
live I'm not sure what that means still
make
still make the same jokes um you said so
far from reality to too late is party
line of government surveillance
inflation vax mandate so that's all
written sort of very telegraphic style
but do you remember enough about what
this is to respond I do and can you like
you've got to set the scene because the
question doesn't so this person asked a
question back at 1 30 I had forgotten
when 138 was but it was uh somewhere in
Portland
and the question was roughly what what
do you predict if uh a group of
important powerful people all had
agis at their disposal that dwarfed
human intelligence and could therefore
inform them strategically
I don't read my answer the way you read
it at all there's one thing that's
obviously
you were right in some sense that that
scenario
was apparently very close because I do
believe we are either in the AGI era or
about to enter it and that means all
those powerful people will effectively
have this at their disposal
I did not laugh off the question at all
I said
that it was Far Enough from reality that
it was impossible to predict and I still
you know it obviously wasn't far off in
time
so if you're looking for an
acknowledgment that I didn't see that we
were at the dawn of that era you're
right on the other hand I would ask you
when I put out this paper that I wrote
in 2016
um
you should read that and see how far off
you think I was because I think I did
realize that there was not very much
necessary to take us from where we were
into this new era and I did not know
where we were in
2022 and episode 138 happened but
nonetheless I can't have been terribly
far off if I saw it coming effectively
right away in 2016.
um the jokes that you're referring to
were at the end of answering that
question where you and I were batting
some stuff back and forth about things
you know I mean basically if you look at
the principles that I've
put out so far on how to deal with AGI
one of them is uh don't assume you know
anything about this era because it's
impossible to predict from what you
think you know right so effectively I
didn't give you much of an answer about
what I would predict because a you would
need to know something about are they
using the same AGI are these agis
against themselves or do they each get a
separate AGI or some combination of
these two things which we did explore
but then you and I joked about some
things
these various personalities might want
to ask their agis about it I haven't
gone back and re-listened but like he
proposes like this who are the
personalities he mentions Elon Musk Elon
Musk who I said was going to ask the AGI
to you know get memes to Mars first or
something yeah it was frivolous but yeah
it wasn't dismissive of the question
right it was just given that we can't
say anything about this because we don't
know what agis we're talking about and
we couldn't predict anything about how
AGI is going to interact with
geopolitics because it's by definition
unpredictable once you're over the Event
Horizon you know you and I were just
having a good time but it wasn't
dismissive of the question yeah and I
mean I guess I think I read into this uh
frustration
that he I presume thinks that you or we
didn't take his question seriously I
don't I don't think that's the case at
all but I also more importantly
um read as is very often the case a
desire for people who think that they
have an idea about something to have
someone the only thing that will be read
is taking it seriously is ah yes this is
going to happen and here's what it will
look like and one of the themes of
especially
um very often the thinking that you do
is what we need to know how to do is get
to the right slope of the right Hill in
the Adaptive landscape and I don't know
what happens thereafter like what what
is upslope of that is is not clear but
we need to get to the slope and the and
then go and so requests for very precise
predictions are precisely not
um not necessarily going to happen
because
because that that belies the the very
thinking behind the answer like actually
we don't think we know exactly what will
happen but we're concerned about all of
these early possibilities let's try to
get on to the right starting Place yeah
or another way to say it is we are over
the Event Horizon as you and I have
talked about and that's what an event
horizon is you can't see what's going to
happen afterwards it's unpredictable yep
okay another AI question if AI discovers
quantum physics it's Quantum particle
technology
okay I think let me try reading that
again with different punctuation if AR
discovers quantum physics it's Quantum
particle technology and accelerates its
own understanding of it will that make
it omnipotent
nothing will make it omnipotent
um
yeah
yeah I wonder I wonder I don't know what
to do with it I wonder if this person is
really talking about quantum physics
or if they're talking about Quantum
Computing that's one of the dangers here
is that
the either AGI comes in contact with
Quantum Computing or more likely AGI
solves fundamental issues that are
obstructing us from Quantum Computing
Define quantum Computing I can't but
basically the idea is the computers we
have are limited by the physics of the
transistors that are used to make them
and there is another way of using uh
using quantum mechanics and the
um basically you're not using resistors
oh yeah not using yeah
hold on let me finish and then you tell
me if I've got it wrong
the issue of quantum superposition can
be used to calculate and the amount of
computing power the rapidity of this
mechanism if it is harnessed correctly
is such that for example things that
with conventional computers would take
thousands of years codes that would take
thousands of years to crack with Brute
Force you know like pgp uh cryptography
would instantly break open or nearly
instantly break open because the leap in
computing power would be so substantial
so if you get a self-augmenting Ai
and it
gains control of or unleashes Quantum
computing power which then gets
leveraged by the AGI the point is how
rapidly are we moving out of a realm
that we understand anything about yeah
it's not omnipotence but it's
effectively so yeah actually so I may
just embarrass myself because I don't
I'm not an expert in this at all but as
far as I have heard or remember it I
believe it is that instead of basing
everything on a binary one position or
the other
um you know ones and zeros that there
are an infinite number of positions in
between and that is the fundamental way
in which
Quantum creating works or that's the
door that is open that allows it to
function I don't know how that works or
I don't think that can be right but
anyway let's that's what I've heard
let's not explore yeah I may be wrong to
figure out after the stream you and I
will figure out uh
that also doesn't
I don't know how that would work but
interesting in this case
all right next question
Joe Rogan recently theorized that AI is
behind all the societal sabotage we've
seen How likely is it that our
leadership is run by Bots
I I did see Joe's discussion of this and
I will point out that in parallel with
what Joe proposes
that you should consider the time
traveling money printer interacts with
AI
hypothesis that we put on the table a
few weeks back right in other words it
is possible that AI is farther ahead
than we think and that somebody is
leveraging their knowledge
of what is coming to position themselves
in the world so that's a that is short
of Joe's hypothesis Joe's
Joe's hypothesis as he put it on the
table and I'm not saying when I say his
hypothesis I don't know that uh in The
Cold Light of Day Joe thinks that this
is what is happening but he thinks it is
worth considering the possibility that
the artificial general intelligence is
effectively he is concerned about the
top layer of
uh existential threat that we discussed
we discussed five different ways in
which AGI could be devastating not
mutually exclusive the top one was the
AGI views this as a competitor and seeks
to displace us
Joe's point is
if it were the AGI were more advanced
than we think and it did view us as a
competitor and was trying to displace us
you would expect some broad scale
sabotage like what we effectively are
seeing I don't think you need AGI to
explain that sabotage you need something
to have gotten into our system either
through
political corruption or through the
manipulation of information so that we
have been led to understand ourselves to
be somewhere different than we are and
are now you know the way same way
terrorists leverage your own beer to get
you to harm yourself more than they can
harm you
saboteurs could leverage control over
our psychological state in order to get
us to deploy remedies that were actually
poisonous right I don't necessarily
think that's what's going on but
something is going on we do appear to be
doing the inverse of all the right
things across many domains that does
sound like sabotage it does not sound
like uh Decay and so it I do believe it
demands an explanation I don't I don't
think Joe's right I don't think his
hypothesis is right
um whether or not he believes it is
right I don't know
um but
nonetheless you've got
conventional
sabotage
enemies who've gotten into our system
somehow you've got
um
time traveling money printer leveraging
AI months ahead of what's coming
um or what we think is coming and then
you've got
um
other kinds of dysfunction like standard
eruption
yep I'd say those three are the biggies
okay
a couple of
covety covety questions the first one
isn't actually but
um please do terrain versus G germ
Theory virology versus toxicology
no proof of viruses contagion so I'm not
sure that's exactly a question and but I
don't know if that's
worth responding to sounds to me like a
germ theory of disease is wrong yep sort
of question and no doubt The Germ theory
of disease is wrong and some substantial
elements because it's a primitive Theory
um
a lot would have to be true the the
there are no viruses thing is obviously
wrong yeah we can see certain kinds of
viruses and scanning electron
micrographs and things you know
bacteriophages are visible they clearly
exist uh so anyway I don't I I have not
gone down this rabbit worn
um
and it's not you know I'm not scared I'm
not worried that it's gonna unravel a
whole nother set of things that I
thought I believed and certainly there's
a lot of that going on right but
it just it feels like on the surface
but precisely some of the reasons that
you just laid out and and others as well
is like there are some things that are
being claimed in this broad sphere that
just are apparently not true and it's
mixed in with stuff that oh I don't know
I honestly don't know maybe probably not
but maybe uh and the burden seems to
come to
um the default assumption seems to be
you people who think viruses are real
and the germ theory of disease explains
some things
um need to defend your position and we
who don't think viruses are real and
don't think the German theory of disease
explains anything have the default
position of where in the right and
that's actually that's reversing the
burden of proof wow so I I I
in order to consider any of this at all
would need to be presented with a very
careful very streamlined very cogent and
well organized but simple and well
referenced
um written piece that laid out what the
claims are and I've not seen anything
like that
it is also the case that the number of
things that could be true that turn
everything on its head is large yeah are
we overlooking some that might actually
turn everything on their head quite
possibly because what do you expect us
to do investigate all of them and you
know you know 999 out of a thousand of
these things are dry Wells and then one
spits oil at you right well it's all
well and good to say ah you missed the
oil well and the point is well how shall
I divide my time right am I going to
pursue you know you tell me viruses
don't exist I tell you I've seen
electron micrographs of viruses you tell
me ah well they don't cause disease how
do they not cause disease if they invade
creatures and they commandeer enough
Machinery to make more viruses it seems
to me obvious they will have some cost
well and also you just changed your
argument yes they do exist ah well but
then like okay
if you make a claim and it's rebutted
and you say yes but it doesn't matter
because like then your starting claim
doesn't matter but if I hadn't been able
to hear about it that would be the thing
that stands like the whole thing just
seems very dicey at The Logical level
and at the rhetorical level as well well
yeah The Logical level is the one you
know
the the guide to whether or not to spend
your time on some really radical
departure from what you think you know
you know I'm not afraid of radical
departures I mean right
that's what we do but yeah um but the
point is
if viruses don't exist why don't they
exist it seems like the kind of thing
Evolution would create and it does seem
to have done so with respect to bacteria
so why would it not do so with respect
to eukaryotes okay so viruses probably
exist if they exist why do they cause
disease well because anything you do
that interacts with this highly uh
refined Machinery of cells that causes
them to deviate to some other job is
going to cause a pathology is it
measurable I don't know but it certainly
seems like some of them would be right
right so anyway the point is the number
of not the same thing as saying are all
the viruses that are pointed at as
causal in all of the diseases that they
are described as causing uh an
accurately diagnosed no like in fact I
can say with nearly 100 certainty that
at least some of those aren't right
right and in fact you know we covered
the
um
the question of how much of Spanish Flu
was actually theatrogenic harm caused by
aspirin right that's not to say that
there was no flu of course there was but
um
but the point is we are absolutely open
to the idea that the causality isn't
exactly as it's been presented right but
in order to get us to look at something
that really just upends everything like
The Germ theory of disease isn't right
the point is yeah that's a high bar and
I'm not even it's not even like well I
just sent you 200 pages that you know if
you read them you'd know it was garbage
it's like well
there are a lot of 200 pages I could
read which one should I invest in this
one does not seem especially likely to
be right it seems like
questioning the relationship between
particular viruses and particular
syndromes is liable to frequently result
in US discovering the things aren't as
we imagine yes but the the fundamental
question about whether or not viruses
exist and cause disease seems unlikely
to be upended just by virtue of the fact
that selections should have created such
things seems to have created such things
and pathology is certainly a likely
result of disrupting any functional
mechanism
I guess I'll add one more thing here and
again I have not gone into
the arguments of the people who've tried
this sort of thing out but it seems to
me that often then Downstream of that is
and therefore none of the vaccines are
making sense because no germ theory of
disease
put that aside for the moment what I
don't think I've ever heard and maybe
I've just missed it is
um and therefore antibiotics don't make
any sense and are never effective I
don't think I've ever I don't think that
is part of the of of this set of
arguments and if it's not
then what is it that they claim
antibiotics are doing if not working
within the model that is the germ theory
of disease so antibiotics like you get
antibiotic resistance like it it all
follows very understandable very
comprehensible evolutionary rules
antibiotics are incredibly powerful
they're totally overused they work
brilliantly until they don't because
there's too much of it and you didn't uh
you didn't kill everything off entirely
and so you bred resistance like this is
all understandable in a framework of The
Germ theory of disease and if the people
who are going after the germ theory of
disease and viruses don't exist and
everything and are going after vaccines
but not including antibiotics in their
complaint list to me that's a giant red
flag right there I agree and I would
also say that the thing about a vaccine
and a virus is
okay somebody injects you with something
and you don't get sick you don't know
that there's a relationship between
these two things right you don't know
that you would have gotten sick anyway
right whereas let's say you have an
infection on your skin and you put an
ointment on it and it goes away where it
didn't for a month before you put it on
right you can detect that pattern so the
point is certainly seems like the germ
theory of disease is borne out in that
case and I agree with you uh I don't
know exactly what this person who asked
the question what their if if their
concern is limited to viruses but yes it
does seem like there's a lot of very
broad well if it's if the if the issue
if it's germ theory of disease which is
the thing that gets started out that
people think is not real at all then you
gotta include the bacteria and sorry
antibiotics work right
um if it's not germ theory of disease
widely if it's actually viruses aren't
what we think they are that is a very
that is a different and far narrower
argument and needs to be made precisely
in order to get the attention of the
people whom you would like to have the
attention of yep
okay let's do oh boy uh let's do two
more quickly okay
um ah the other coveted one since
Omicron have you seen any new coveted
variants why either way
yeah it's a great question uh yeah I'm
the cynical part of me
thinks well the Omicron rollout didn't
go as planned and so they're on to other
things but I mean the newly
eu8 or whatever the the like the new
shots are half of them a crown half
original and like why they're including
any original is its own version of
stupidity but Omicron from that was
into 2021 was it like beginning of 2022
like what
come on what is happening I mean
the basics I would argue is that the
variants were actually driven by the
vaccine campaign
so you might well expect that the
evolution was happening faster during
active
um sudden onset of mass vaccinations not
only active but
to the EXT if they had
if they're freaking pseudo vaccine
worked then they should have updated it
with each
um with each variant
they didn't
and it is possible that the reason they
didn't was because they did not want to
generate a detectable pattern where they
were causing the variance and that could
be tracked
so
there's always been a question about
what Omicron is and where it came from
and uh I suppose there's also a question
about what the relationship is between
what's in their new bivalent uh was bang
injecto stuff
um and Omicron but the question is look
there's all this proprietary stuff we're
not allowed to know and there's an
obvious evolutionary question about the
relationship between the proprietary
stuff and trust us
right
um but anyway I don't know I I guess
what I would like is full transparency
on what's in the vaccines
um what the testing actually reveals I
don't I don't want the trust this stuff
and and
yep it's not going to happen yeah it's
not going to happen Okay one more
question
and it's a big one and it's actually one
that
friend of ours and I are actively
engaging and trying to figure out how
deep to go
um
the trans movement reverses the normal
order of human development it sexualizes
kids then leaves them incapable of
sexual pleasure or reproduction as
adults
is this intentional or a strange
coincidence
and you know and the the
what could possibly explain
the level of
Insanity that we are embracing on this
topic
now and I haven't exactly heard or
thought it framed precisely this way
reversing the normal order of human
development sexualizing kids then
rendering them both incapable of
pleasure and infertile
as adults but
it does seem like we've got
billions of years of history of
of reproduction that worked and you know
a few hundred thousand
a couple hundred thousand years as fully
modern anatomically modern human beings
in which childhood was long and
um you know older you know young teens
and older children may be engaged in
some Explorations and some play and all
and there were presumably very rarely
um developmental abnormalities where a
child of one sex really felt that they
fit in best as the other sex but this
was incredibly rare and
this went on for Generation after
generation after generation and suddenly
suddenly everything is haywire
and I believe I've not gone back and
looked I actually don't even know where
the book is but I believe that Camille
Paglia and sexual personae her big her
massive Tome from the 90s
argues I just heard someone say that she
argues this so I have not fact checked
this but that she argues that
um at the point that civilizations
become this confused sexually is
basically the harbinger of society-wide
call apps and I think she's more precise
than that I don't know exactly what her
argument is but
um
so that's that's one one concern but it
doesn't get at the larger question of
what is what is happening like if if
it's the sort of peglia argument which
is that
as things begin to unravel
sexual disorder and um celebration of
completely nonsensical sexual
positions sounds wrong but you know
beliefs and such become normalized
um that's a sort of this is an effect of
something that was already happening but
there is also the question of maybe we
are being driven into this maybe there
is something either something more you
know some forces at play or you know a
combination of forces at play and you
know hormones in the water supply and
you know just there's so much all at
once
that seem that's half ish of people in
the weird world are going like yeah
that's right men can become women it's
cool to sterilize children chop them off
you doing
wasn't protect the children one of the
most most obvious things that we all
agreed on
until yesterday
so how could fully have
of the weird world
be going along with us
yeah I think they're
two components here one of them is the
sheer novelty of the mechanisms by which
we amplify social beliefs Etc we're all
connected together so it's not like some
group can go nuts and it doesn't affect
us all
um obviously
we have a case where
you know it's a phony consensus thing
right obviously these claims are
extraordinary
and yet we have very powerful forces
including the platforms and government
effectively
enforcing
a censorship regime and punishing those
who defect such that it seems like we
have broad agreement which of course
makes a thing more contagious because
you know like ah I'm with those guys I
don't really I'm not so sure what this
is right because there is no those guys
there's a tiny number of people who are
obviously awful who are complaining
about these you know new bits of wisdom
right for most people's perspective
anyway yeah
um so that's one thing and then I also
think that there's something you know
this is a millenarian death cult that is
being imposed at a scale that is not
normal
right and it's that you know
millenarianism is a thing it happens and
the modern amplification phenomena is a
new thing that apparently happens and
those two things are coming together so
the weird
anti-natal instinct is
um being broadcast through a megaphone
with a
dozie-like entity punishing anybody who
plugs their ears and that combination is
doing this at a scale that we've never
seen yeah
um facilitated by as you said both the
medical technology
and the social media
landscape yeah both of which are novel I
mean it's it's hyper novelty piled on
top of hyper novelty
um with a foundation of good
old-fashioned mob Dynamics group think
and wanting to belong
and
um you know this this is this is how you
end up drinking the Kool-Aid
yeah
it's literally in some cases yeah
all right yeah okay happy Birthday
everyone
we got tulips you can't see the Tulips
we had the Tulips for you guys yeah
what's that
oh can you smell the Tulip sucks as you
can smell the Tulips oh you probably saw
in the daffodils we've also got
daffodils yeah it's the daffodils it
smells like they're entitled to smell
the Tulips we doubt that you can smell I
don't actually think tulips really small
the daffodils do though they're lovely
okay well we can go put our noses in
tulips and daffodils and we hope that
you have the opportunity to do so as
well unless you're listening from the
southern hemisphere in which case bundle
up winter is coming
yes
um sometimes you have stop and argue
about the flowers yes somehow as long as
you have to stop and argue about
smelling the flowers and yeah
um so we'll be back next week uh same
time same place no q a next week
and uh and then the following week we'll
actually be delayed by a few days we'll
be doing it on
did I decide Tuesday May something 9th
10th yeah something but next week
which will be April 29th my mother's
birthday
regular time regular place
and uh we look forward to um it sounds
weird but you seeing us that because
we're not going to see you then
um until then
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
foreign